bonjour christopher yano bonjour madame
et bonne année merci à vous aussi une
très belle année on va parler de katalin
nova qui va devenir pour la première
fois à priori là la première présidente
de hongrie qui est elle exactement
alors qu est l hymne au bec
jeune femme dynamique intelligente
francophones et on écrit comme vous le
disais elle serait donc la première
présidente de la république hongroise
dans l'histoire du pays
elle est d'ailleurs
auparavant elle était aux six mois dans
les affaires étrangères ainsi que dans
les affaires familiales elle était
chargé d'un dossier plus tôt plutôt
difficile parce qu'effectivement la
hongrie comme beaucoup d'autres pays
dans l'union européenne font face et une
crise devait de décroissance
démographique depuis plusieurs décennies
donc la tâche avec laquelle a été
confiée je pense qu'elle a très bien
très bien l'exécuter membres du fis
l'aise c'est je pense qu'elle est en
tête du parti des relations étrangères
du parti du fitness depuis 2007 oui vous
l'avez dit à l'ats elle a beaucoup
havrais pour une politique familiale
d'ailleurs il ya un ministère de la
famille en hongrie ce qui est une
particularité + 30 % de natalité grâce à
elle le pays est en manque est en manque
de bébé
je pense que si le quai est
malheureusement dans beaucoup de pays où
effectivement on peut constater qu'il ya
une décroissance dans
dans les dents les aspects
démographiques mais effectivement son
mandat a d'ailleurs fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle un ministère sans portefeuille
donc il faut pas nécessairement voir
aménorrhée ministère avec des centaines
à boire même des milliers de gens qui
travaillent mais elle était plutôt
justement chargé de l'exécuter la tâche
de mettre en vigueur ou de mettre en
oeuvre un système plutôt
soutenu de soutenance aux familles
nombreuses parce qu'effectivement on
sait que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
avoir des enfants ça pose beaucoup
beaucoup de défis notamment sur le plan
financier
et juste en haut des priorités
de madame de vagues c'était d'assurer
que avoir des enfants n'était pas
l'équivalent d'avoir des désavantages du
côté financier et d'autre côté voit la
politique incitative d'allocations aux
parents elle a trois enfants vous l'avez
dit ce qui n'a pas empêché de mener une
carrière brillante elle a d'ailleurs mis
entre parenthèses sa carrière pour
élever ses enfants c'est une proche de
viktor orban
je pense que oui parce qu'en fin de
compte les avec le parti de filet ce
depuis relativement longtemps elle
détient je pense une position dans
l'exécutif du parti est d'autant plus je
pense qu'elle est effectivement en ligne
donc elle est d'accord avec avec les
principes qui sont généralement non
seulement celle de victor obame est
ainsi conseillé du gouvernement hongrois
alors qu'en face l'opposition et qui est
assez critique vis-à-vis de l'ancien
président quelles sont d'ailleurs les
réels pouvoirs du président hongrois bon
alors l'opposition évidemment ils sont
critiques parce que bien que on peut
entendre des nouvelles au contraire je
construis la démocratie est encore
relativement m'arrêter en hongrie
l'opposition peut critiquer sans devoir
faire face dès des conséquences néfastes
alors il faut savoir que hongrie le
système c'est plutôt un système
parlementaire ils n'ont pas de système
présidentiel monsieur mais
présidentielle comme vous l'avez en
france en france on parle souvent du
bicéphalisme de l'exécutif cependant en
hongrie bien qu'on ait un président ou
une présidente
le cas échéant maintenant
il est ville où elle est donc le chef de
l'état en droit il est pour cinq ans par
le parlement
donc c'est en fin de compte un système
de suffrage indirect
le collège électoral dans le cas
d'élection présidentielle envahi et donc
les 199 membres du parlement
pour que quelqu'un soit ou puisse être
présenté en tant que candidat à cette
élection présidentielle il faut qu'il
ait le pack il ou elle pardon et le
parrainage d'au moins un cinquième des
députés ce qui veut dire étant donné que
le parlement hongrois est couramment
ce qui composait de 199 membres il faut
qu'ils aient au moins le personnage de
40 de 40 députés
l'élection présidentielle alors en ce
moment notre président monsieur vient
aux chats d'air il est
président jusqu'au 10 mai 2022 est donc
selon la constitution l'éviction des
nouveaux de la nouvelle présidente doit
avoir lieu au moins 30 jours mais au
maximum 60 jours avant l'expiration du
terme du président actuel donc je pense
qu'on peut s'attendre à une élection
dans le dans les deux-trois mois qui
arrivent en principe est d'autant plus
nous aurons des élections législatives
au mois d'avril alors justement est-ce
que ça peut être un atout ce tandem est
ce que ça peut être un atout pour la
victoire en panne pour les législatives
de ce point de vue là je lui dirais que
comme je les décris au départ nous avons
pas comment nous n'avons pas le même
système de bicéphalisme de l'exécutif
comme vous l'avez en france le président
ou la présidente
effectivement elle a mille où elle a
comme tâche
le rassemblement du parlement ou même la
dissolution du parlement la nomination
du premier ministre et de certaines
ministrable ainsi que d'autres positions
évidemment en cours pour tout le monde
c'est la priorité c'est d'avoir le
respect de la démocratie de respect du
voeu du peuple si je peux citer à un
ancien premier ministre stephen harper
communiste du canada suite à cette
défaite en 2015 vis-à-vis justin fielder
il avait quand même déclaré que le
peuple a toujours raison donc les
électeurs ont toujours raison je pense
que en ce qui concerne votre question
oui ce sera intéressant de voir
comment comment se déroulent les
élections au mois d'avril mais
effectivement je pense que le tandem
sera sera moins moi significatifs comme
elle le serait en france par exemple
dans une cohabitation sa personnalité à
catherine novak on sait qu on vous
l'avait dit le président n'a pas
vraiment de rôle exécutif il peut
néanmoins impulser des lois est-ce
qu'elle aura son mot à dire
absolument oui parce que vienne le
président actuel monsieur adhèrent bien
que il est membre du parti politique
actuelle au pouvoir il ya plusieurs
reprises il avait renvoyé certaines
projet de loi pour que ce soit pour
qu'elle soit soit réexaminé par le
parlement il ou elle le président a
aussi le droit de tourner vers la cour
constitutionnelle hongrie qui est en
camp compte l'institution principal pour
déterminer si une loi est en règle avec
la constitution
concernant cette personnalité comme je
l'aï dit je pense que évidemment le rôle
selon la définition constitutionnel en
hongrie demande que la personne soit
quelqu'un qui rassemble et qui tient en
compte les intérêts de tous les endroits
mais bon en principe on peut dire que
c'est aussi la tâche du gouvernement
donc j'espère que
ça sera évidemment à un grand défi pour
elle mais je pense qu'elle est tout à
fait capable
de se placer dans cette position comme
je l'indiquais les jeunes et les
dynamiques qui est si on tient compte
des tech qui ont été confiés jusqu'à
présent je pense qu'elle a fait un très
bon travail jusqu'à présent merci
beaucoup christopher you know d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions dans la mesure où l'on
surnommé france